un día de interrupción y resistencia
hacían llamado los activistas a su
protesta Nacional de este martes en
Israel que generó caos en el aeropuerto
bengurion cortaron el tráfico en tel
aviv y se manifestaron ante el tribunal
supremo en Jerusalén
he venido aquí para protestar contra la
reforma legal y judicial del gobierno
israelí tal y como yo lo veo será el fin
de la democracia israelí y no
permitiremos que ocurra
[Música]
las principales carreteras también han
sido bloqueadas como esta que lleva
Jerusalén en un intento desesperado por
sofocar las manifestaciones la policía
israelí ha utilizado cañones de agua y
arrastrado a los manifestantes por la
fuerza
durante una protesta En haifa este
reportero gráfico fue empujado al suelo
antes de ser escoltado por la policía
la causa de la indignación el parlamento
aprobó el lunes la primera de las tres
lecturas de un proyecto de reforma
judicial muy cuestionado las reformas
pretenden frenar El poder del tribunal
supremo el Primer Ministro israelí
Benjamín netanyahu ha afirmado Que hará
más eficaz la gobernanza al limitar la
intervención de los tribunales pero
muchos Siguen sin estar convencidos
desde principios de año decenas de miles
de personas han salido a las calles cada
sábado para protestar